[Music]
what's up this is the third episode of
congratulations we did it we did it this
is the first official this is the in
history this is the first third episode
of congratulations in history and that's
amazing we did it and these episodes are
[ __ ] coming out every week as
long as you know people continue to
that's what I actually want you to do if
you would screenshot this right now and
put it on your Instagram and say I'm
listening to Christa Lea's new podcast
and tell people to listen to it or tweet
it right now get on your phone you're on
your phone because you're listening to
it and then just switch out of the app
and go to the Twitter one and tell
people to and link it to you know what I
mean help them [ __ ] out and
because I'll tell you what I'm gonna do
this until the wheels fall off like I'm
going to do this until the wheels fall
off and this is what I mean by the
wheels falling off if people stopped
listening if we're going if we don't
because right now well I think we right
now we're number six in comedy which is
awesome and it was number two and that's
fine of course it's going to taper off
because you know the curiosity factors
like oh what's this new podcast and it
goes down a little bit but you know
let's keep riding that [ __ ] wave
because you guys are you guys deserve
some congratulations so yeah we're where
I'm here I'm back I'm back in town I
went to Atlanta this this past week I
was there for two nights Atlanta a
hundred percent I love it because it's
the most Atlanta place of all time
Atlanta's a place where you literally
will see like if you're not if you're
not in a room every other room has a
black guy in it with a [ __ ] red suit
or something like that you know like
like I was at Starbucks and I literally
saw a dude a black dude in in a purple
suit and it what the thing was it wasn't
his it wasn't like he was showing up to
Starbuck
to get a coffee to go somewhere where he
needed to have the purple suit he had
the purple suit that was a Starbucks
suit they'd be who's there he put the
suit on no doubt to go to Starbucks to
[ __ ] have this meeting that [ __ ] is
amazing because the amazing part was is
he was not a King of Comedy
all right he wasn't [ __ ] deal Hughley
or cedric entertainer he was just some
guy that was at starbucks that was like
this is what I wear which is amazing
that's the outfits you see in Atlanta
are [ __ ] that uh is like it's like the
lollipop guild is what it is it's
amazing dude I got a knot this wasn't
this time in Atlanta but the last time I
got off an elevator in Atlanta the
elevator opened up and I this girl had
the biggest ass
I couldn't even [ __ ] believe it it
was it was enormous and it she wasn't
fat it wasn't like you know she has a
big ass because her body's big she had
like a back like a trunk dude it was
amazing dude she had a trunk her she
didn't have an ass she had a trunk that
you need keys to and you open it up and
you put [ __ ] in there like a duffel bag
that's what she had like you could
literally I wanted to tap her on the
shoulder and be like excuse me ma'am I
kit and she'd be like yes I said I can't
find my duffel bag can I check your
trunk and she wouldn't have looked at me
weird she would have just turned around
and offered her ass that's honestly how
much that's that's how much her her ass
was a trunk and that's some Atlanta [ __ ]
dude that's some [ __ ] Atlanta [ __ ] it
that was amazing
I couldn't believe it do it and dude the
asses in Atlanta are car crap and I'm
not not not even try be sexual about it
I'm not saying like hot damn you know
I'm just saying it's a fact you could
you can literally set up your [ __ ]
laptop on you [ __ ] that you can put a
desktop on it and have just put them put
the modem or whatever like next to her
and set up a coffee cup and and and and
literally not have to use one of these
tables at Starbucks and have that
meeting with that black guy in the
purple suit I mean unbelievable um so
yeah so it late but besides that Atlanta
was great I had two shows I had to throw
one guy out actually I didn't throw the
guy out the first time the first time I
got on stage as soon as I got on stage
dude was trying to recite my my [ __ ]
from my last special incorrigible and it
was just so annoying and I was like yo
you got to be quiet you got to shut the
[ __ ] up and then when security went over
to go talk to him about it he was like
bobbing and weaving like he got knocked
the [ __ ] out like he was so drunk he was
so [ __ ] drunk do it anyway and then
they kicked him out this is my favorite
when they kick somebody out and nobody
else goes with them because you know
either they showed up a lone drunk which
is SS sad or they [ __ ] nobody like
well that were with him were like oh
[ __ ] him he's on his own I want to see
Chris D'Elia or whatever [ __ ] concert
you're at that's hilarious to be like
yeah he's my friend but [ __ ] he ruined
it which is how I think people should be
um but yeah so it was it was it was a
young guy I feel kind of bad cuz you
probably woke up he probably and here's
the thing too at that in the lobby
afterwards you know he was like I don't
understand what got kicked out I was
just laughs and I was just no you
weren't
naw you reciting my other [ __ ] which
makes no sense now let me do my new [ __ ]
so but the Atlanta shows were good
the crowds are awesome in Atlanta
they're really great man I was at that
center stage or center theater I forget
what it's called I was going to shoot my
special there almost but I did not
because the theater the stage was too
high I wanted to do a little bit more of
an intimate thing so I'm going to
Vancouver to do it and it's sold out I
think so you can't get tickets anymore
but I am setting up dates everywhere
else so anyway I did the Atlantis show
and now I'm back in LA and I I'm excited
about this podcast I'm excited about
being here I'm excited about being able
to do this every week and people are
like hey you know you should get this
guy on at that kind as a guest I'm not
going to do guests and that's and I'm
not I'm not saying I'm never going to do
guests but I'm just going to do it me
until I'm just like so tired of [ __ ]
talking that might be next week and
maybe you'll see somebody come on the
podcast but but I it's just - it's just
it I don't like I don't want to be
interrupted this is what it what it is
and if you don't like it that's fine um
a lot of people don't like my [ __ ] I
love how I love how it reminds me of
this week which the Grammys came which I
didn't even watch but but lil yachty
wore that dough off he looked terrible I
mean he here's a deal man and I posted
the picture of lil yachty if you don't
know what he put in his mouth he had
like these like now and later colored
multicolored you know it looked like the
gay-pride each tooth was a different
color and and he had those red dreads
that look like a [ __ ] a red tarantula
[ __ ] passed out on his on his head it
was ugly as [ __ ] and I tweeted about how
this is the ugliest thing I've ever seen
in my life and here's the thing people
were like oh you're hating your you know
don't don't hate let him do what he
wants you know he could do what he wants
but you're telling me that he put those
[ __ ] things in his teeth and those
dreads those those red neon red [ __ ]
things on his on his head you're telling
me he did that to look handsome you're
telling me that he did that so somebody
would be like oh wow he looks handsome
no he was on purpose trying to look ugly
that's it I'm not hating I'm agreeing
with him good job you did it you have a
freedom of expression and you did it
it looks like a glowworm is in your
mouth congratulations
it looks like a [ __ ] starfish passed
out on your [ __ ] head and you have
the KFC [ __ ] bowtie
you did it you're not you're not you
know look you're not saying oh yeah I
wanna look handsome you're saying I look
ridiculous and that in turn looks
horrible and that's fine
but don't say I'm talking [ __ ] if I
[ __ ] walk around with a dick on my
forehead like a molded dick and a
[ __ ] star you know just like some
[ __ ] cutout star on my on my nose I'm
talking [ __ ] about myself if I do that
without even saying anything it looks
bad
that's fine because there's that that's
the thing there are opinions that are
opinions and then there are opinions
that are facts if you walk around with a
dick on your forehead it's ugly
sorry but it is I'm not sorry but it is
if you walk around and it looks like
[ __ ] Rainbow Brite took a [ __ ] in
your mouth it looks bad okay so CeeLo
showed up looked like [ __ ] c-3po
before he did the Atkins diet he looked
like a [ __ ] I mean he looked it
wasn't even ugly it was just it was it
this was beyond words but what the [ __ ]
man hey make music and Cee Lo's talented
- [ __ ] I don't know little yachties
music really
um but Cee Lo is talented so just stick
with that bro why do you have to show up
looking like the thing you're trying to
win he was gold as [ __ ] and looked like
he was about to fight the Power Rangers
yo make a song dude hey man make a
[ __ ] song oh dude you dressed like
that
oh that doesn't matter make three songs
dude it's so annoyed he didn't even have
a mask on like that you would buy in a
hollow like a Halloween thing he like
with the strap in the back this [ __ ]
thing was like done by mission by like
the Mission Impossible or no not even
like the [ __ ] Lemony Snicket's
[ __ ] costume or
uh-uh what do you call it the [ __ ]
makeup team where it was like the one
that the made Jim Carrey bald with the
[ __ ] hook nose or whatever the [ __ ]
he was like you know Cielo was like I
got to get the [ __ ] I gotta get the
Lemony Snicket's I got to get the limine
Snicket's [ __ ] crack team because
I've got an idea
and they said what did you use your idea
CeeLo and they were like just [ __ ]
hang out in this room I'll be right back
and then it came out looking like he was
going to blast off into outer space
which is the only reason why you should
look like that
hey dude if you're gonna dress like that
fine but after the Grammys blast off
into the [ __ ] outer space
no c3p no see no see lo see no make
[ __ ] three songs unbelievable man and
then and then the people said I was
being racist because I was saying they
lil yachty was being ridiculous huh
you're real quick got question huh what
the [ __ ] are you talkin about
huh dude I don't give a [ __ ] of the guys
white or Asian or any I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't dude if you show up like
that you look ugly it's it is it is my
my my hands on top my my hands at I now
go lunch go to lunch that's what I say
De Niro did this [ __ ] line greatest
line in [ __ ] cinematic history in
this movie Copland and the Niro is mad
at some dude and he just says my hands
are tired now go to lunch that's what I
say now every time I [ __ ] mean
something by the way it's less echoey in
here we did the [ __ ] we put up this
uh we got this gaff gaffer tape and we
put the the what do you call it the foam
[ __ ] up and it's fallin down dude it's
like the end of that [ __ ] movie the
gods are good the gods of Egypt when
they're fighting each other and you got
you got a
Gerard Butler fighting that [ __ ]
blonde dude from Lord of the not Lord of
the Rings the [ __ ] winter is coming
show and and and and the and
everything's falling except there's it's
way less cool because no gods of Egypt
are fighting and it's just me and my
producer in a [ __ ] small room in a
podcast with a bunch of [ __ ] foam
squares falling down but I like to think
it's like gods of Egypt it's it's it's
it's it's it's less ridiculous than gods
of Egypt that's a plain movie by the way
yeah oh by the way [ __ ] and that's
that's where a Cee Lo needed to be with
that outfit on is gods of Egypt so yes
so so the Grammys happened I didn't
watch it and then Beyonce performed
pregnant which is pretty [ __ ] awesome
actually I know I joke around about a
lot of stuff but I saw like a Jeff of it
or a gif however you pronounce it and I
saw it and it was it's pretty crazy she
did that with twins that's pretty insane
yeah that was pretty [ __ ] insane um
and so so yeah so the Grammys and then
the [ __ ] and that happened um you
have a people lit me up man for making
fun of I mean might a lot of people like
it but people lit me up no matter what
you do people light you the [ __ ] up man
if you have a following people light you
the [ __ ] up I'm just trying to [ __ ]
get mine dude I'm just trying to do what
I do and do comedy you don't think it's
funny hey man move on go follow [ __ ]
John Legend or something right I mean
he's good I like John Legend he's
talented his [ __ ] go look at his stuff
you don't think I'm fun and go [ __ ]
follow you know jeremy renner he's got
some good [ __ ] up there some [ __ ]
cool you know he looks cool in his
[ __ ] sunglasses and he walks dope
good go follow him I love my favorite
thing is on it my favorite thing though
is on Instagram is the people who sing
is the people who [ __ ] seriously sing
not people
who sing who do that but people who
don't sing but decide to do that it's so
funny man it's so funny when somebody's
all of a sudden you follow somebody and
then all of a sudden they put up a post
and they're like I can help falling in
love and you're like uh hey what are you
doing hey man what are you doing dude
it's usually well I don't since usually
it's either of some [ __ ] punk
fourteen-year-old kid with hit with hair
that looks like he's in Jimmy Neutron or
a thirty year old woman who's like who
feels like and I'm not saying that this
is true because I think thirty year old
women are hot as [ __ ] but who feels like
that they got to do something else now
that the now that they can't pose on a
rock anymore or near a motorcycle
they're like aw [ __ ]
can't [ __ ] pose on a motorcycle
anymore here we go do I can help
and then they post it up and they only
post like their mouth singing you know
cuz they didn't do makeup that day or
some [ __ ] I love I love that it's so
funny like that like there's this thing
that goes on in stand-up comedy to where
like a woman turns 30 and they're like
ah [ __ ] gotta do stand-up comedy now
like guys are stopping guys or guys are
starting to stop pay attention paying
attention to me because there's like 21
year old girls that they'll pay
attention to so now I will literally
stand on stage so they will be looking
at me by the way nobody ever said I was
funny I'll just go up and be funny you
know what this is a travesty dude this
is why social media is a travesty I love
social media I'm gonna do what the [ __ ]
I do but this is why it cuz people will
just be like oh [ __ ] I'm a singer now
dude I can help know pose on a rock pose
on a rock or [ __ ] deuce you know what
I mean like I'm not saying dudes don't
do it dudes do it too
gasps I don't know four dudes is it I
don't know I feel like dudes are not
really like hey I'm 30 I'm gonna be a
singer now but dudes are more like oh
god I don't know what the version of it
for a dude is it's all weird though man
it's this weird [ __ ] sad kind of
social media presence find out what you
do and do it well you know I don't know
I don't know though you know people suck
at their [ __ ] job and that's you know
on one hand it's like do I want to be
mad at them for not doing their job
right or you know I don't know or or is
it they're just is it them thinking I
just got to get a job I got to [ __ ]
make money you know I'm not talking
about the singing thing on Instagram but
like you know a guy who's gonna [ __ ]
you know a technician or a plumber that
comes in you know I guess to be
passionate about plumbing is not
something that is really you know you
that's usually done they just like I
needed a job I [ __ ] fell into it I
there goes another [ __ ] gods of Egypt
[ __ ] thing fell but yeah so I don't
know people don't want to get real jobs
so they just [ __ ] sing on Instagram
[ __ ] part more power to you to the
people who really try to do [ __ ] and
[ __ ] make a clothing line or design
some jewelry or start a [ __ ] podcast
or whatever the [ __ ] you're trying to do
I know no I actually I take that podcast
thing back no sorry don't start a
podcast don't start a podcast with your
friends don't do that save us
don't start a [ __ ] podcast with your
friends dude don't do that just figure
it out in a different way go back to
school if you're going to sing on
Instagram go back to school if you're 30
and you're going to sing on Instagram go
get a degree but I don't know what the
[ __ ] do I know we live in Hollywood
though that's what's going to happen you
in Hollywood that's what's going to
happen dude these billboards have been
popping around with the YouTube red [ __ ]
though imagine watching something on
YouTube bread imagine watching imagine
being like imagine getting home from a
day of work working hard sweating or
dealing with a bunch of clients annoying
his [ __ ] you didn't want to do that you
know and you're like I just want to
[ __ ] unwind you don't have a family
or maybe you do you got a girl and you
go home and you and you heat up the
chicken that's in your fridge and then
you turn on YouTube red imagine that row
what are what are the [ __ ] shows that
they have every show on YouTube red
should be called zinc's that should be
every show on YouTube red every show on
YouTube red is called joinx
I don't give a [ __ ] if it's not it is
you look them up look up the shows
everybody on the [ __ ] posters is
making this face zoinks dude come on man
do it and there and what's happening
what's happening dude see that's what's
happening you see these things and you
think well I have a youtube account I'm
going to sing that's what happens you
see the [ __ ] YouTube red [ __ ] this
shows called zoinks and you're like ah
that's like a step away from me but it's
not dude dude this YouTube red [ __ ] I
don't know man you have to subscribe
subscribe to it everybody wants you to
subscribe to their [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
have I talked about this yet it's been 2
episodes I feel like I'm [ __ ] already
backtracking dude hey if I want to
[ __ ] massage I don't want to have to
subscribe to some [ __ ] you know I'm
talking about
if I want to buy pants I don't want to
have to then get an email from Saks
Fifth Avenue every five hours I think I
talked about it LinkedIn the [ __ ] is
LinkedIn I gotta get a I gotta get a a
mail from LinkedIn I haven't even signed
up for LinkedIn I'm a comedian the [ __ ]
do I need people in my social network
for on LinkedIn nah come on man stop
emailing me dude I woke up today I had
42 emails
two of them were important other ones
for like from [ __ ] PayPal let me look
at night deleted a lot of them PayPal
[ __ ] some some I pick movie [ __ ] Saks
Fifth Avenue there's one red fin come on
man Amazon fine Travelocity the [ __ ] is
that never signed up for Travelocity
what's going on man I got to get a new
email I got a new [ __ ] email dude hey
Oh yo Amazon stop suggesting [ __ ] to me
Amazon suggests chap [ __ ] 12:12
bundle of chapstick the [ __ ] dude if I
bought a 12 bundle of chapstick on
Amazon drown me and then throw a [ __ ]
plugged in toaster dude I'm gonna go to
Amazon if I need to go to [ __ ] Amazon
okay I'm gonna go to Amazon if I need
some equipment or some [ __ ] or some
swimmies you know what I mean but
[ __ ] don't send me a link to hey
here's a 12-pack to chapstick on Amazon
I can go to the gas station there's
always a gas station down the block
YouTube Redman these billboards are out
of control they're popping up everywhere
dude never seen that show billions but
that [ __ ] billboard is the most
serious billboard of all time they
should call that show cancer and I'm not
saying it's a bad show it's probably an
amazing show that dude with the red hair
and red body is in it and [ __ ] the
you know the guy from the guy from the
Claire Danes show right isn't it that
that's that guy right from I know I
never know that names a [ __ ] Damian
Lewis he's from homeland right he was on
that and now he's on [ __ ] billions
billions is what's it about two guys in
like a building or something I Paul
Giamatti is amazing Paul Giamatti is
[ __ ] awesome dude
um but but that [ __ ] billboard hey
man have some levity in that billboard
dude you know what they need on that
billboard on a billions you know what
they need they need a guy from YouTube
read in the back with the [ __ ] zoinks
face that's what they need I mean
they're literally there's one where
they're facing off what would it it's
not it's not gods of Egypt its billions
is these guys in business right and
they're fighting over who's making money
I don't know what the [ __ ] but they're
staring at each other like each of them
murdered their child like Paul Giamatti
murdered Damian Lewis's child and Damian
Lewis murdered Paul Giamatti child
another facing off like it's [ __ ] UFC
387 it's probably an amazing show dude
but like if you're fighting zombies have
that right but these guys are just like
it's billions I don't even know I don't
know but what the [ __ ] do I know look
I'm an I'm an idiot I'm just telling you
how I feel and what I've seen
everyone's so [ __ ] serious about
everything man
everything and then you make fun of
something and then they take it
seriously they get you mad they get mad
I want a world where you can just you
know what I want a world I want a world
where if [ __ ] two dudes drive by in a
convertible and and and nah not even
I'll date more than two three dudes they
got two dudes in the front two dudes in
the back and a convertible and I've seen
that I've literally witnessed that with
my own eyes I've seen two dudes in the
front of a convertible and then two
dudes in the back for dudes total in one
convertible driving down with the top
down I've seen that with my own human
eyes I want a world where we live in
where when that happens everyone else
who's not in that convertible laughs at
them and then everyone in that
convertible understands why that's the
world I want to live in do it where it's
okay to laugh at those [ __ ] and
we understand why because pretty soon
we're going to have a [ __ ] support
group against that [ __ ] we're going to
have the four guys can be and it's
convertible if we want if they want to
and we're proud of them if they want to
we're proud of them if that's what
they're doing
we made a [ __ ] myspace group against
it for in favor of the four guys in a
convertible not are you up dude if if if
you had a convertible and there were
three dudes and they were like hey Chris
jump in no I can't imagine the amount of
money you'd have to get me to do that
[ __ ] there's a price but I think it's 20
grand you can't do it and and then even
if I was easy okay here's the check so I
hop in I expect everyone to laugh at me
if not everyone's laughing at me [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them right in their [ __ ]
closed car [ __ ] laughs [ __ ]
that's horrible
imagine lil yachty and CeeLo
and then [ __ ] the two dudes from
billions in one convertible that's the
funniest thing I could ever imagine and
the two dudes and billions are looking
at each other so goddamn serious and the
funniest thing I could ever imagine we
need a world like that okay to where as
if someone's gonna say hey well hey what
the [ __ ] does the future is female mean
man what does that mean it's okay to ask
that right cuz it doesn't feel like it
it doesn't feel like it it feels like if
I were to stop somebody who wore a shirt
that said future is female and say yo
what the [ __ ] that mean future doesn't
have a dick and balls or [ __ ] can't be
female or male that I would be the
[ __ ] I would be the [ __ ] me for
asking that question
I don't like coined [ __ ] you know I
don't like [ __ ] that everyone gets
behind either I don't even like that I
don't like I don't like when everyone
gets behind some [ __ ] that bothers me
dude it bothers me Beyonce is the most
talented [ __ ] person it bothers me
how everyone just jumps on the [ __ ]
thing and is like oh [ __ ] she's amazing
dude if I tweeted Beyonce sucked which I
don't think if I did that it would I
don't think I'm famous enough but
there's people that are famous enough
that if they did that it would be news
it would be a [ __ ] hate crime if you
said that nah the future is not female
you know why because it's the future
that's why doesn't have a dick and balls
or [ __ ] don't assign genders to things
that are intangible don't do that
what's a cloud is a cloud male or female
yeah
can't I can't I just I don't know man
I'm drinking soda water I used to hate
it because it just like confuse the [ __ ]
out of me because when I was young I
would drink Coke and and Pepsi and [ __ ]
and then I would my dad would drink soda
water and I would drink the soda water
and I would be like what the [ __ ] it has
the absence of flavor and I was like I
would just drink water but now I tell
myself to like it bro I taught myself to
like it cuz I don't want to get [ __ ]
cancer
because you know you get that when you
drink Pepsi coke so now I drink [ __ ]
Perrier man because you got to do that
because that's what you got to look out
for the [ __ ] because the future is
female man and you got to [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] imagine what does that mean I
want to know what that means like that
mean what you mean you know what I mean
just me say what you mean and mean what
you mean dude they call [ __ ] little
yacht e boat somebody said look what
boat showed up in row oh god man and
like seriously said it look what boat
showed up in if you say look what boat
showed up in when I look I want to see a
goddamn boat you know I'm
YouTube's bread somebody make it show on
YouTube bread call it zoinks I tell you
what man it's a half an hour and I
already feel like I'm out of [ __ ] to
[ __ ] doubt people are like people
people say uh it that uh they didn't you
know well I mean a lot of people like
the pockets which I'm happy about but
some people were like yell bro you're
just talking that's what a [ __ ]
podcast is I'm going to do this I'm not
going to have guests until I need to I
feel like and then I'm gonna like but
I'm gonna get like astronauts on here
and like why me not that they would do
it but I would want to try get them on
there and just [ __ ] like ask him all
sorts of [ __ ] about outer space and ask
him why you know what the [ __ ] they're
Dylan doing and what they do every day
and I want to ask astronauts what they
think about dudes who [ __ ] are in
convertibles with with four dudes I want
to get the normal man the working man
the guy that works at Crate & Barrel I
want to ask him in in in in Iowa that's
what I want
so ya huh I'm looking around this room
and there's literally half of the
[ __ ] little panels are up it looks
horrible
there's just tape on the wall oh uh but
by the way I saw the [ __ ] I watched
this [ __ ] a little bit last night uh
this on Netflix the life on the road
with David Brent this [ __ ] [ __ ]
killed me do it first of all the office
the British office is my favorite show
of all time hands down like you're
talking comedy you talking drama this is
my favorite show it's so [ __ ] funny
and this thing came out and I guess it's
like [ __ ] it's probably fifteen years
later not not quite but um and it's a
follow up and it's about how the you
know the character David Brent is trying
to come up with trying to do it go on
tour now in a band and live his dream do
it about thirty minutes and I was
laughing already
but about thirty minutes in I just
started
it really started getting to me and I
just started laughing and I just didn't
[ __ ] stop dude this [ __ ] movie is
so funny the character that this guy
does is just incredible i dude every
ounce and [ __ ] percentage of this
character that he made is so funny and
so real and so you know everybody kind
of knows a version of a guy like that
you know it's pretty amped up but it's
just still grounded and real it's just
so funny man it's so funny you have to
watch it this guy is so funny and if you
haven't seen the British office watch
that too it goddamn this movies so funny
I was rolling in my bed laughing rolling
around laughing in a like a [ __ ]
idiot just giggling um and I'm so
[ __ ] sore from I'm so [ __ ] sore
from working out by the way well I work
out now and I've done it for months and
I'm trying to get in shape you know or
you know just be healthy really and keep
moving because I'm 36 but uh how do you
do it I'm always in pain I'm not talking
about sore like I'll [ __ ] pull my
back or like that'll get better into my
shoulder and then that'll get better and
then like it's my foot or some [ __ ] is
that just gonna happen the rest of my
life it just what good are you always
training it was somethings have to has
to hurt you
I'm not even do it's not I'm not doing
[ __ ] MMA I'm jumping up and down on a
[ __ ] half ball I'm pulling bands how
is this happening I think I think
honestly I just got the [ __ ] shorter
than this stick when I come to when it
came to running around God was like mmm
you can be you know you can have an long
hair but we're gonna pull your back
whenever you try to move you know I
think that's what it was dude I feel
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] man I used to do
jiu-jitsu for [ __ ] six years I felt
fine maybe I was demand just getting
older you know maybe that's what it was
maybe that's what it is I don't know by
the way I asked you guys to like ask me
questions and use the hashtag
congratulations pot hey guys
get with the program man you [ __ ]
asked me what there was one good
question
one I'll answer it now somebody asked me
if what what the sketchiest a show I
ever did was and it's probably the one I
talked about an incorrigible with with
the where the lady attacked me if you
haven't watched in court if you haven't
watched incorrigible watch it that's
actually that bit is on the firt is like
the first bit I do so you don't have to
watch the whole thing but watch the
whole [ __ ] thing and I I this lady I
called she had like really crazy frizzy
hair and I said and she was like a
heckling or something and she said
something and then I said I called her
Blanca because member the Street Fighter
2 thing with the frizzy hair and then
she attacked me like like Blanca but she
came up and like grab the microphone and
it [ __ ] hit my mouth and [ __ ] and I
just kind of like sat down because you
know she was a woman and oh I mean I
don't know but I was deep in the valley
man they got these crazy open mics man I
don't know if they do any mom I'm sure
they do but there used to be a website I
don't know if there still is called
chuckle ha chuckle ha
something-something chuckle something
and it would show the open mics all
around I mean I remember how I felt dude
when I would when I would look up this
[ __ ] in my old apartment and I'd be like
oh there's an open mic there oh man
maybe I could go to this one maybe I
could go to [ __ ] you know Mo's cafe
or whatever the [ __ ] it was and I would
go there and goddamn the feeling I have
I have like the nostalgia I have about
that was just it's just so crazy man to
think about that to think about starting
some [ __ ] like that it's just in
saying and the rooms I had to play
all right drove out once it was like two
hours away I drove out with a guy that
was doing stand-up at the time who his
name was Phil Verone and he was a good
guy I haven't talked to him in a while
but he used to play the guitar for skid
row I think um I think it was Skid Row
but he yeah he was a buddy of mine and
we drove out to some place in the middle
of nowhere it was like past I don't even
know where it was man but we got there
and there was a show and I did about 10
minutes and we drove back to ours that's
and you know you made I made like my
don't even know maybe 50 bucks but it's
so [ __ ] crazy to think that that [ __ ]
see that's the thing did a lot of people
do extend if I was talking about these
people who turned 30 and they're just
like oh I want to do stand-up now but
they only want to do shows at the Comedy
Store but you got a [ __ ] you got a
you got a [ __ ] you got to go through
the trenches men on stand-up you gotta
you gotta [ __ ] fail so hard and I
perform for one person before literally
like it was some rich queen that order
to me but it wasn't it was at some
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know some spot never
liked the show still go and go ahead and
I went I just [ __ ] perform for one
woman in a jean jacket and I was just
like talking to her I guess kind of and
then one time I went to the comedy store
this is before I was like on TV and [ __ ]
and I would just go late sometimes like
1:00 a.m. to hope I would get on and I
got there like midnight and they were
like hey nobody's here you want to go on
and I was like [ __ ] yeah and they were
like okay there's two people in the
audience and I was I got [ __ ] well
whatever I'll still go up and they
literally were like one of they said one
of them is dr. Dre and I said nah I
don't want to go up because I don't want
to look like an [ __ ] in front of dr.
Dre so I said now I think I'll skip it
it was the first time I
like said no to a spot and the host at
the time was like Don Barris at the time
he was like hey dude I know why you
don't want to go up cuz who's in the
audience but this is what you do you're
a [ __ ] comedian and you go up and he
and I was like you're right I'll do it
I'll [ __ ] it I'll do it and I went up
and I and I and I went up and I
performed for dr. Dre and another dude
and they were the only people in the
audience and I just talked to dr. Dre
while I was onstage and I you know I did
crowd work cuz you can't what am I could
go up and be like man isn't it funny how
you know dr. J's gonna be like ya know
so I was like I just was like hey what's
up dude like he was in the back by the
way all the way in the back so it wasn't
even like he was in front of me I
couldn't even see him its darkest [ __ ]
the Comedy Store and I was making fun I
was talking to dr. Dre and then he
started heckling me a little bit you
know lightly heckling me just because I
was talking to him he wasn't even being
disrespectful but then I was like I
remember the one thing I said is like I
can't believe how [ __ ] dr. Dre you're
getting on me and then I started like
making fun of him and he was laughing a
little bit I think from what I remember
unless that's my ego candy-coating it
but uh I think it was and then
afterwards I got offstage and when I got
offstage another guy got on stage and
dr. Dre left after I was on and then I
was out on the patio now people are like
oh you just performed dr. Dre that's
crazy and allowing other peers and
comedians and [ __ ] and then and then dr.
Dre walks out and he walks past over and
I was like can I get a picture can I get
a picture and dr. Dre said is like no
he's waving him off and I was like [ __ ]
man I would love to get a picture with
dr. Dre I wonder if he would get a
picture with me because like he like saw
me perform you know and like not that it
gives his [ __ ] but like maybe he would
like at least feel something about that
so he walked out of the comedy store and
and I was like it was the make-or-break
time where it was going to be too late
to ask him because he was already
leaving he was outside walking away
I already told a bunch of people no and
in like I'm it was like in the cinematic
moment in my life
think I'll ever forget it I just
screamed out hey Dre like I know him and
then he in my memory he stopped and like
there was a beat where like he in his
head he went oh no who the [ __ ] that
must be even though he didn't in my head
that's how like the beat was because it
was like a pregnant [ __ ] pause that I
improbably imagined because it was so
dramatic for me to do it and he pivoted
around like Tony Gwynn taking that step
[ __ ] knocking that ball out of the
park dude squashing the bug saw me and
then I said in the probably what was the
most insecure [ __ ] way possible he you
think I could get a pic and then another
beat and he just [ __ ] saunters over
in that [ __ ] dr. dre gate and then
just walks over and I'm I get the phone
ready and I [ __ ] and he was like yeah
man and I walked and I and I put my arm
around him or whatever I think I did and
then I took a picture somebody took a
picture for me I remember who and then I
said thanks man I really appreciate it
and then he walked away and I was like
that's so cool that like he definitely
only did that because I was performing
and I don't know in my head it was like
oh yeah okay he respects it before
because I would other people that were
asking were just people there that he
didn't you know not that he knew who I
was but he did after that because I he's
like okay that's the comedian yeah and
it felt [ __ ] cool that he respected
it and that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I don't
know man
I think about that sometimes and I think
about how like it's cool um to do that
and like I mean dude they don't
people don't forget that [ __ ] so don't
forget that [ __ ] so yeah so that's
what's up but that was cool as [ __ ]
there was it was funny though that that
happened I'm really it really anyway
more of the stories I'm really [ __ ]
happy that I've you know performed for
my I did it I would have regretted it
dude I would have [ __ ] regretted it
man
that's your [ __ ] inspiration for the
day dude is just do it and right
that's why Nike is so successful part of
the reason dude just do it man I went up
there and I did it I made my legs move
up onto the stage that's what I did I
literally thought if I could just make
my legs move and walk if I just move the
[ __ ] legs to get up on the stage and
I'll be on stage and then I have to talk
so yeah
and I wore the dumbest shirt that day
and now I have that picture and I have
the [ __ ] dumbest shirt on with a
sweat pit stains because I was so
nervous I was twenty eight seven I think
twenty eight anyway so yeah that's
what's up that's what's going to be man
it's 45 minutes I did it I want to come
with more [ __ ] to talk about next time
but these come out a Monday night
silently and then I'll [ __ ] tweet
about it and subscribe to it though so
you could get it when you get it and
then Tuesday it'll be there for your
commute or whatever the [ __ ] or you want
to listen to it at work and so this was
episode three of congratulations you can
tweet me or ask me questions
congratulations pod is the hashtag
subscribe to it on the on iTunes and
rate and review it that would be great
it will be helpful and tell people you
listen to it man and try to spread this
out because bro if this [ __ ] thing
crashes and burns you know there's gonna
be like a but like the hardcore
listeners that are going to listen to it
and they're gonna and I'm not going to
do it anymore so it's you gotta [ __ ]
help me out and help you out by [ __ ]
getting this [ __ ] out there man or
otherwise I won't give a [ __ ] but I do
like I you know it's fun but so yeah so
rate and review it on iTunes and post
about it and get the word out there if
you if you give a [ __ ] if you don't want
it don't do it I mean I'm not [ __ ]
you know but uh yeah so that's that's it
and then what else do I need to say I
got tour dates coming up Chris D'Elia
calm
Chris D'Elia calm I'm going to be in
Raleigh Virginia Beach Australia Tempe I
got all these dates coming up and more
being added and definitely don't ask me
what I'm going to be coming to wherever
because it's all up in my [ __ ]
website and yeah that's it thanks for
listening and remember man futures the
future by
[Music]
you